success on YouTube is 80% mindset and
20% mechanics the mechanics are the how
to's it's the tips
it's the thumbnails it's the tactics
it's how do you actually turn on
monetization on your video but the
mindset come on that's the psychology
that's about how do you actually get
yourself to take action
punch fear in the face press record put
out the right videos and in this video
we're gonna be sharing five money
mindsets that you need to succeed when
it comes to making money on YouTube
there's a lot of valuable content coming
up this week on the think marketing
podcast so buckle your seatbelt and
let's get into it the number one podcast
for growing and scaling your business
with online video I'm your host Heather
Torres and I'm Shawn Cannell and we're
from think media and if this is your
first time listening thanks for being
here this show is dedicated to helping
you learn how to get your content notice
and the latest money-making strategies
that are working right now online so
whether you want to grow a YouTube
channel or you want to maximize video
across all of social media this podcast
is for you
this is part 2 on how to make money on
YouTube five money mindsets you need to
succeed and I want to encourage you if
you missed part one go back and Spotify
or Apple iTunes podcasts or on the
YouTube channel and listen to part one
because this is ten total money mindsets
that are needed to succeed now if you
made it this far and you're thinking
about bailing on the episode lean in
even more I know that for some of us we
understand the power of mindset but then
sometimes we also think man give me just
the tactics bro give me this strategies
man what's the little trick that's gonna
help me make more money with affiliate
marketing or YouTube ads and the tactics
do matter they're critical but I heard
Tony Robbins say and I've seen this
truth over and over that 80% of success
is due to psychology mindset beliefs and
emotions and 20% of success is due to
strategy the specific steps needed to
accomplish a result and
seen this over and over because listen I
was telling my wife Sonia the other day
I'm watching this guy primal swole jur
on on Instagram he's a guy who does a
lot of body weight exercises
he's got kettlebells dude is ripped you
know mostly what I do is I literally
just watch his kettlebell workouts and I
think man I'm gonna do that someday
Mike that one looks awesome I click save
on it you know I think I worked out even
I watched it on Instagram he's like it's
like a three-part series I watch all
today I'm like oh that one looks cool I
should try that one later and then I
like click the Save button and I was
getting ready to buy his course you know
which I still plan to do because I love
him I love his content I want to support
him and I was like Sonia I'm so excited
because I'm gonna buy his kettlebell
course and guess what she said to me she
was like how about you just lift up the
kettlebell that you already have
sheepishly and questioning whether or
not my wife
even respects me just kidding you know I
was like man that is so true and listen
it's not that I don't need his course I
absolutely wanted I believe that
lifelong leaders are lifelong learners
and that online courses are the shortcut
to getting the right information in the
right steps
I love his free content on Instagram and
I'm gonna invest in his course as well
but she was so right and what I realized
was listen it was it's the mindset it's
the beliefs it's the inner game that
leads me to taking action it's not how
to do the workouts listen if information
change people alone we'd all be healthy
wealthy fit rich smart but a lot of
times we get in our own way it's our own
inner game our own mindset it's our
value system our BS that gets in our own
way our belief system and so that's why
we're talking about money mindsets and
specific money mindsets that gave me a
framework of not just earning money with
YouTube and eventually reaching
financial freedom building a powerful
business now helping hundreds and
thousands do that as well through our
products and
programs but really money mindsets that
I also believe are critical to have true
legacy and lasting success listen in
this industry and I get it I get accused
of this there's a lot of gurus or
quote-unquote you know people that that
have kind of a vibe of like kind of get
rich quick kind of a vibe of like dude
you're just some scammy guy on the
internet and the truth is there's a lot
of guys like that man I bend it like I
could tell you about events I've been to
and like very weird cocktail parties
where people are like yo let's just
figure out or give some people's money
man and I'm like dude that is just
freakin sick like that's gross like I
feel weird after like I got to go pray
and take a shower and you know because
there there are people out there who who
have I believe the wrong belief system
the wrong foundation and and if you're
trying to get rich quick you know it's
actually a proverb that says an
inheritance gained too fast in the
beginning won't be blessed in the end
oftentimes if you actually even get rich
quick or you get rich with compromise
it'll destroy your life I mean it's not
gonna actually lead to true success so
what's the point we gotta have the right
mindset that at the end of the day if
you want to build lasting wealth and
legacy you don't do it by cheating
someone you do it by adding value you do
it by helping people that business that
it's ethical to sell its ethical to
serve it's ethical to solve problems
that business is one of the best things
we can do to serve humanity and serve
all of God's children by solving a
specific problem so that's what we're
learning about what these money mindsets
and I've learned that a lot of times we
can get tripped up either in having the
right kind of success on YouTube and we
shrink back from really leaning into
making money in the right way or we
sometimes just don't even have the right
framework where we're trying to if you
will cash in too soon we don't realize
that influence comes first and that
income comes second and that really
money as a result of how much value you
add to the marketplace it's it's the
result of serving people and true legacy
true wealth and true wealth and business
as a result of adding massive value and
so the
money mindsets have been shaped by a lot
of mentors they've been shaped by from
me from biblical truths which I believe
are woven into the DNA fabric of the
universe and that these are like almost
like universal laws that God woven to
the universe that when you follow the
principles like you will be blessed like
it's the way things work like when you
add value and treat people right and do
business with ethics and integrity you
will be rewarded like who would have
thought like if you're a man or woman of
your word and your yes is yes and your
no is no things will go well for you my
gosh in 2020 what a revelation but you
know in all seriousness like powerful
values and principles which apply all
the way to YouTube Adsense believe it or
not so a little bit of a different style
of content then maybe we normally do but
I believe this is absolutely critical to
success so get ready for today's
featured content today's episode is
brought to you by video ranking Academy
and if you want to learn more about that
you can go to start VR a.com that's the
word start and then V are a stands for
video ranking Academy comm and we'll
talk a little bit more about that later
but the session you're about to hear is
part two from a session in video ranking
Academy now the majority of it's our
signature course an online coaching
program for YouTube the majority of the
course is actually about the tactics
side it's about the strategy side the
mechanics side of success on YouTube
thumbnails strategy research before you
press record in fact we have a
proprietary system that is the seven R's
of youtube influence the seven VRA ours
and that's what video ranking Academy is
all about again you can learn more about
that at start VR a calm but what you're
about to hear is a session that's a
little bit different right it's more on
the psychology piece which is critical
it's about the mindset it's about the
beliefs it's about the emotions to true
success so get ready for this session
and
dive into the featured content hello and
welcome back to the video ranking
Academy I'm fired up because in this
session we're gonna be talking about the
next five money mindsets this is part
two of the mindset needed to create a
high impact and high profit YouTube
channel again this is my perspective and
position just kind of some things I've
learned that have helped me in business
in YouTube and in making a difference
and as a reminder our mission here at
think media is to help people build
their influence with online video in
social media you know the title of this
is not just how to make a high profit
but also a high impact YouTube channel
our passion is to help Purpose Driven
entrepreneurs purpose-driven creators
people that are heart centered people
that have faith that the world could be
a better place and are sharing messages
that matter on YouTube but the thing is
you know you need money for the mission
that's one of the mindsets it's that you
gotta start with building influence
because you need to be actually having
some followers and subscribers how can
you impact anybody if no one's listening
to you or no one's discovered you yet
that leads to income so you can fund the
dream and really make a difference and
then ultimately impact which is not just
the content that you're sharing but it's
also of course the difference you can
make once revenue really starts to come
in and as a reminder you know this
program is built in this session is a
little bit different than what we are
talking about in most of the sessions
than VRA you know video raking Academy
is mostly about strategy the how to's
the tips the tricks and that is critical
because if you don't have the right
strategies the right wisdom the right
gameplan sunsoo the famous military
general told us every battle is won
before it's even fought that's a
strategy that's reverse-engineering the
first are in the seven r's of the VRA
system you got to start with the end in
mind
you got a reverse-engineer the strategy
here's what I've learned strategy is
only really about 20% of success on
YouTube it's the how to's the tricks the
tips the tactics in a way it's
information right like if information
alone changed people we'd all be healthy
wealthy skinny
and ripped like Brad Pitt and fight
Fight Club come on that's my goal and I
have not reached it yet
it just keeps okay right like if
information really changed us then we'd
all just have those results but we need
more than information to get results and
so the point of this program is also the
community aspect that's why we've got
our private Facebook group that's why we
do the q and A's that's why we share
stories every month from the VRA show
show me your friends and I'll show you
your future right you're an average of
the five people that you spend the most
time with and even the books you read
and what you listen to so when you get
in the right community you start to step
into an environment where all things are
possible but then the last ones
psychology right this is really the
three essential ingredients I think of
succeeding at anything business
entrepreneurship and YouTube but the
bottom two are oftentimes not talked
about we just think if I have the right
thumbnail if I get my tags right if I
get my title right sure but if you don't
have the right psychology
listen doubt kills more dreams than
failure ever will
that's psychology we just talked to a
student who was wondering should I keep
going I'm not sure if this is working I
feel like quitting and I looked at his
channel and I saw that he was getting
62,000 views every month and he had only
been on YouTube for seven months and I
was like my god
sixty-two thousand eyeballs watched your
content if we're talking eyeballs a
hundred and twenty thousand come on you
know okay so like a lot of people and
you've only been doing this for seven
months but I don't blame him
because I think we all can relate to
wishing this was going faster wondering
if this is working self doubt self
criticism do I have what it takes
does anybody care and even his channel
was going by 400 subscribers a month but
even by seeing that growth it was is
this even working I'm like 400
subscribers a month like what would it
be like for a business to get 400 new
customers a month what would it be like
to have you know 62,000 people watching
your Khan
and listening to your like if you would
have told my grandparents about that my
grandfather Lowell Reid who fought in
World War two as an Air Force pilot and
who after serving started a dental
clinic and he was a dentist if you if I
could have told him like hey you want to
get in front of sixty-two thousand
people a month that could be potential
customers for your business for free by
the way by just creating content and
putting it on YouTube lolz in heaven now
but I imagine if I told him what I was
doing with YouTube right now and that
this month we got 4.1 million views on a
free platform where we put hustle in and
where we could like rank videos and
search and where we could do all this if
I told him I was like yeah you know when
you were building your dental practice I
know you had to buy ads in the newspaper
and try to get word-of-mouth and try to
get customers but here's what I do I sit
at home and I talked to a camera and I
talk about tech and gear and CNBC just
did a video about me and like where
where did it all come from like did did
you go to school for it not even go to
school for it well how much did it cost
you to get in front of those 4.1 million
people are the sixty-two thousand people
well grandpa it didn't cost me anything
I can tell you I don't think they allow
violence in heaven but if I was having
that conversation with grandpa Lowell in
heaven I promise you he punched me in my
face like he would literally just be
like wait a minute
you got 4.1 million views from sitting
at your home shooting videos on a
smartphone come on using the Internet
you'd even leave your house and you're
getting in front of that many people and
then you know how grandparents talk
right he'd be like when I was when I was
young I walked to school uphill both
ways with no shoes on in the snow with
not you know what I mean and he would
look at the circumstances in the
situation that we have and he would
probably just be so shocked by the
opportunity by the possibility listen
why do I say all that because our
psychology matters our perspective
matters our mindset matters our mindset
matter
when we're losing because you might not
be getting sixty-two thousand video
views yet you may not have posted yet or
you may have posted a hundred videos and
they're still only getting ten views
each you still need psychology to
persevere to not quit to keep going
psychology that believes and knows that
if you don't quit you win sometimes you
win sometimes you learn and so these are
all the elements and that's what this
session is all about and it's a little
bit different than what we normally talk
about right and we just went through the
first five money mindsets
but in this session we're gonna be going
through the next one and it's money
mindset number six so write this down
and it's this if you consider your work
to be a calling and your way of serving
humanity you will be able to make money
and provide value simultaneously these
money mindsets have been building and
the goal here this is how this has
worked for me on YouTube my goal has
been to align your work with your values
and align your values with your work we
believe there's nothing wrong with
wanting to make money right but make
serving your goal like money is a
consequence of serving other humans so
when your YouTube channel the way you
entertain the way you educate consider
your work to be a calling it's your way
of serving humanity and then you'll be
able to make money and provide value
simultaneously in the last session we
talked about again money is the
consequence of adding massive value
money is the consequence of serving
another human being it's not the goal
it's something that we understand will
happen it will return to us it's
something that will enter our life
because when you deliver value when you
solve a problem when you put a smile on
someone's face when you delight a viewer
the result by the way you know what
YouTube has right now they have a
department called satisfaction it's one
of the algorithmic metrics is what is
the viewer satisfaction and the
algorithm is trying to satisfy the
viewer in the last session we were
learning about do you think about the
viewer first or are you creating selfish
content and thinking about yourself
first and what you want to say what you
want to talk about listen money mindset
number six if you consider your work to
be a calling in your way of serving
humanity you're going to be able to make
money and provide
you simultaneously these are money
mindsets that have served me to say man
I want to take my passion I want to take
what I love but I also want to think
about the viewer first and think about
what would add value to them how can I
make this product review the best ever
how can I help this person learn their
camera how can I get to the point fast I
want to watch back my video that I'm
editing through the eyes of the viewer
well how would this make the viewer feel
feel would they get bored here am i
going off on a tangent here I just want
to have that mindset and I want to think
through the lens of man my youtube
channel is just a gift it's serving it's
helping and here's the thing man we just
got this gold play button just got
featured on CNBC we just got you know
the number one best-selling YouTube
strategy book in the world these results
were built on the foundation of me just
wanting to start a YouTube channel that
serves that gives that adds as much
value as possible you could write this
down make it your goal to add more value
than your competitors and this is even a
competition I mean it is in business for
sure but it's it's a competition with
yourself but that's that's the question
who's adding the most value who's who's
adding the most value and if you even if
you co well I don't know if I can add
more value what can you add more value
than you did yesterday can you make your
videos more valuable more satisfying to
the viewer then you're gonna get better
results on YouTube money mindset number
seven your income is directly correlated
to the amount of buy buttons you have on
your website okay lean in for this one
this sale this one seems weird cuz it's
like we just learned right in a past
session about okay YouTube ads affiliate
marketing brand deals crowdfunding and
and those ones potentially don't have
any buy buttons on your website but what
we learn numbers I've was that selling
something 1,000 true fans is the most
powerful predictable and really
profitable way of actually having a
sustainable income through YouTube so
your income is directly correlated
to the amount of buy buttons you have on
your website this might trouble you
because you might say well Shawn I don't
know if I understand let me ask you a
question how many buy buttons do you
have on your website
Shawn I don't even have a website expect
the first thing like I don't even have a
website let alone buy buttons I don't
even know what I would sell well then
that might be the problem this is money
mindset number seven I remember I sat in
a seminar it cost two thousand dollars
the tickets to this seminar and I was it
was not about YouTube remember YouTube
we don't want to make a living from
YouTube we want to use YouTube to make
our living this is this is just reverse
engineer I'm not saying you got to build
a whole business and build a website and
figure out I'm saying these are the
money mindsets that guided me over the
last few years and helped me build a a
five six multiple six seven multiple
seven-figure business brick by brick by
brick was money mindsets and I remember
I heard this your incomes directly
correlated to the amount of buy buttons
you have on your website I was like what
I have zero buy buttons like how can
people give you money I don't have any
money I'm trying to like work from home
well how do people give you money well
they can't by the way we do a lot of
work with coaches consultants or like
Fitness coaches or mindset or life
coaches and like one of the fastest ways
to actually start making money or
freelancers is to set up a PayPal dot me
Ford / Sean kennel which is the ability
to request money from anybody and say
hey for $100 I will edit a video for you
for $100 I will design you know graphic
design for you or for $100 like Nicole
in our community with video ranking
Academy she's the kids occupational
therapist I'll do a 30-minute session
hoping consult you on on feeding and
latching and some other things and all
of a sudden there's a way for someone to
give you money well I don't even know if
they'd give me money for I don't know
what I would do I don't know what I
would sell I don't know what I would
great good that's that's great these are
the money mindset to actually trouble
you to say what are you actually
building remember this revenue session
is like a safari we're driving through
the world the there like an elephant
over there a zebra over there a tiger
over there we're looking at the
possibilities I want you to have these
as foundational things
how many buy buttons do you have on your
website well then the more buy buttons
you have on your website the more income
you can produce so if I can buy merch a
hoodie from you a mug from you well then
I could give you more money like my
friend Pat Flynn he's got a tripod
called the switch pod that's a Buy
button you can buy a physical product
that he designed
my friends benji and judy travis have
bathrobes
that's a buy button right my friend
Steve Panetta is a real estate agent and
not only is he crushed it with video
ranking academy to send clients calling
him which is also really a Buy button
they sign up for a survey or they sign
up to get in touch with him so he gets
on the phone or they email him and he
either sells them a home or helps them
sell his home and gets five percent
commission right on two hundred thousand
dollar home that's ten thousand dollars
so is he's using YouTube to promote his
real estate business but now he's made a
real estate course that he's launching
launching soon to help other real estate
agents learn video that's a Buy button
my question to you and tell me in the
comments and be honest how many buy
buttons do you have on your website do
you even have a website and this really
ties in and money mindset number eight
but before we get there I just want to
remind you I'm not saying that you need
to panic and have buy buttons tomorrow
like oh shoot I better write an e-book
like oh I better I better like write a
book it's hard to write a book man we
talked about in the last session how by
giving away a book for free the audio
book through audible audible gives you
five dollars every time someone just
signs up for a free membership even if
they cancel and we've made over thirty
thousand dollars by just putting an ad
out for
hey download the YouTube secrets
audiobook for free if you go to tube
secrets audio com you can just see try
audible if you don't have an audible
account you can get the book for free so
Benji and I had to sit down and record
the audiobook put it on online but I but
I digress it took us a long time to put
this all together so I'm not saying you
have to do this for maro I am saying
listen let's think big what's the big
vision you're building with your YouTube
channel what's the bigger business model
you're building with your YouTube
channel what let's reverse engineer and
start with the end in mind but then
let's be patient and make smart moves
because when I heard your income is
directly correlated to the amount of buy
buttons on your website I didn't have
any buy buttons on my website either it
was like five years ago that I heard
that and I was like shoot I was troubled
and I thought huh maybe that's why I'm
not really not making money I was making
like three hundred to five hundred
dollars a month with YouTube ads and
affiliate marketing
but I wasn't thinking big enough and I
wasn't really thinking different and so
your income is directly correlated to
the amount of buy buttons you have on
your website number eight your income is
directly correlated to the amount of
offers you make to the marketplace okay
your income is directly correlated to
the amount of offers you make to the
marketplace
please answer below how many offers did
you make to the marketplace in the last
thirty days I'm getting very
uncomfortable Sean this I don't like
this session zero how much money did you
make in the last thirty days online uh
zero
well if your income is directly
correlated money mindset to the amount
of offers so what does that mean again
if you do a vlog and you put affiliate
links in the description but no one's
watching the vlog with that mindset or
that intent to buy anything what's
probably why you're not doing very good
with affiliate marketing but if you
review a couple products and you say hey
these new things are out right now
there's the Blendtec blender and there's
the Vitamix blender the Vitamix is
better let me
which blenders better and the Vitamix
you know I said I really liked it and
there's a sale on it right now there's a
link in the description it's kind of
like an offer and the audience goes the
viewer goes oh cool well I've been
wanting to get healthy and start
blending up fruit vegetables I'm gonna
buy that you actually are like clearly
just letting people know they can buy
something that's affiliate marketing but
even more directly when talking about
selling something
hey y'all and in the last session two
sessions ago we talked about a thousand
true fans and broke down how to build a
six-figure income right talking about
fly ride from the VRA he's got the
hoodie and if you did a thousand units
of merch once a quarter a thousand units
of your shirt of a hat of whatever and a
thousand true fans and you just did for
merch drops a year that means for merch
sales a sale hey this is for sale you
can buy this thing now don't get
overwhelmed you might be like this I
mean it sounds like a lot of work
because a lot of us look just at YouTube
like can I just like make videos and and
you can and it depends on your business
model and remember we talked about the
two big business models or the business
owner and the content creator but like
at the end of the day if you're wanting
to build a legacy and you're wanting to
build something bigger and you're
wanting to build something come on
that's recession proof that will last
through the ups and the downs of whether
brand deals are happening or CPMs are up
or or the fickleness
of the market and the fickleness of the
algorithm what's the business you're
building strategy number five sell
something we gave like 22 different
examples of things you could sell
there's like so many different options
but you actually have to make offers so
I was doing some coaching with somebody
that does bass guitar lessons so that's
their business they're not a youtuber
there are a music educator using YouTube
to grow their influence like jay-z said
I'm not a businessman I am a business
man right you're not a business woman
you are a business woman right and his
business is I teach people guitar
lessons and he can do it online so I
said he was wanting to reach financial
freedom or at least he wanted to pay his
monthly bills and so he told me the
target was around like 2,000 a month and
he was making 500 a month or so so then
my question was how many offers have you
made to your marketplace on YouTube on
social media on your email list or
whatever he had to made any so I went to
his web YouTube channel and I looked at
the about page and there was no
information that I could even do
business with him and then I was looking
for a URL I said have you made a youtube
video and he had some good guitar and
good tutorial bass guitar tutorials and
stuff and I said have you made a youtube
video letting your audience know how
they can do business with you and he was
like I have not and it seems funny but
with empathy I'm being very serious look
I get it I think there's some fears this
is a mindset in psychology who were
afraid to sell something we're afraid
that someone might be like oh why don't
you just give them any hell away for
free do there's always gonna be that
person but they don't understand life
they don't understand that it is to sell
us to serve and of course you're gonna
give away free information that's what
we've been talking about this whole
thing add value give free value show
you're good for it but at some point
you're just saying if you want to go to
deeper level with with me I'm going to
show you how you go to a deeper level
and you make an offer so then he said
his website needed a ton of work like a
lot of things needed work if you dug
through the crevices of the internet to
even find the page where he could sign
up for his guitar lessons but even still
he's like well when should I make this
offer I was like you should go live
right now like hey just really quick
video YouTube just want to let you know
you know I'm putting out these like -
two free guitar tutorials a week
but I just want you to know like if you
want like a 30-minute session with me
I'm doing a special right now you can
actually they're they're $25 each but
you can get three of them for 50 and
there's a link below in the description
you know just want me to keep posting
videos but if you want to check it out
you can check it out my question to you
is how many offers have you made in the
marketplace in the last 30 days my
question to you is what is your offer
and this is money mindset number eight
because I know that in video ranking
Academy foundations I don't want you to
get distracted remember if you try and
chase two rabbits you end up catching
neither so I want you to I do want you
to build your influence first because
influence comes first income comes
second but we are strategizing game
planning what's the bigger vision what's
the bigger business model your incomes
directly correlated to the amount of buy
buttons which actually by the way means
you've set up a proven sales process
there's like a way to do business with
you that's what I asked him I said how
are you booking clients he said well we
kind of email back and forth takes like
five or six or seven emails to figure
out a time that'll work for both of us I
was like could we improve that process
okay like maybe just use like calendly
calm so that as soon as someone clicks
the Buy button they could schedule the
time so you could sell more sessions and
and what is that so I'll buy button is
it's not just a term the reverse
engineering of what's that gonna mean
okay well I should probably explain on
the page what they're buying and I need
to do like it'll produce another 55
problems to figure out but the buy
button is as soon as like you could
connect with somebody and give them a
way to do business with you then they
can click that and then it takes them to
the next step in the next step that's a
sales process okay but then the offer is
what starts before that like explaining
clearly what you have and how it can
help people explaining clearly how
people could buy your book or your if
you're a comedian
how they could buy your your merch if
you're an entertainer how they could buy
tickets you know again you you make you
say hey I'm doing a private comedy show
link in the description it's only for a
hundred people that's an offer but there
has to be a button to buy the tickets
and there's to be a way to fulfill and
so we don't need to get into all that
and I'm not trying to get us into a
million different directions I'm just
trying to share the money mindsets that
we want to get your income up but it's
directly correlated if the amount o
offers you make to the marketplace and
listen this is why a lot of YouTube
channels fail and it's why a lot of
businesses fail it's the inability to
nail a profitable business model with
proven revenue streams write that down
this is why in VRA foundations we are
starting with the end in mind and
reverse engineering our revenue because
if we are unclear about what our
business model is I assure you our
viewers will be not that that's like
their question but you know what I mean
like if you don't know where you're
going how will you know when you get
there second question Shawn I want to
add more income to my business Shawn I
want to go full-time and quit my job
Shawn I want to create an extra five to
ten thousand dollars a year whatever
your goal is right your goal down be
clear on what your goal is if you're
like but I don't really know what my if
I have a profitable business model well
then you're probably not gonna have one
you know what I mean like clarity is
power and in the last six sessions we've
covered the profitable business models
and we've covered proven revenue streams
but do you see how powerful this is like
can you see what a difference this would
make if you had crystal-clear clarity on
this clarity takes time
clarity takes patience it might take you
a year or two to get clarity and you're
building remember you're getting 1%
better every week uploading a video
every week getting better every week
meet new people you're you're you're
continuing to stack and build right but
this is why they fail because it goes
back so if someone goes why does your
YouTube business fail what was your
business model I don't know what was
your clear
any strange not quite sure how are you
gonna make money couldn't tell you
we talked about how sometimes the reason
that we don't have the support of
friends and family it's not because
they're haters we're gonna get those two
and you got to deal with the fear of
other people's opinions and like who
cares about the haters but sometimes
concern family members or spouses or
partners just the reason their concern
is they lack clarity and if if you can
explain to them look this still has risk
this is gonna be a challenge this is
gonna be something that I'm going to
work at it's not guaranteed nothing is
we might get hit by a meteor in four
seconds from now like what you're like
if we're trying to hedge against every
possible scenario 5g towers might put
pandemic viruses you know into our cells
as the reptilian elites just take over
everything
come on conspiracy theories like wow
that went off the deep end fast the
inability to produce a product like
nothing's guaranteed but we need a
reverse engineer the strategy to plan
and that's what this program is all
about so fill out your clarity worksheet
do the workbook stay committed to video
ranking academies stay in the community
because clarity will come as you take
action and as you keep studying and you
keep taking notes we want to nail down a
profitable business model that aligns
with your niche and you can do it in
everything if you're an entertainer if
you're a vlogger like there's a path to
do it in every single direction but but
you're definitely thinking different 9
out of 10 influencers and I know a lot
of broke influencers that have high
vanity metrics no foundation and they
don't and as soon as a storm comes their
house is built on the sand man as soon
as the storm comes it gets knocked down
just because they haven't really set up
a real business a profitable business
model with a strong foundation with
proven listen revenue streams and I know
I continue I know I continue to say
timeout but I'm not saying you need 45
revenue streams today in fact that could
be dangerous today because it's a
distraction what I am saying as I want
you this whole set of sessions is about
vision it's not the mindset it's about
our psychology right okay let me let me
see the
because I need to start with the end in
mind and then I'm gonna break this down
into phases and work on what I should
work on phase one but now I got a vision
for what phase two three four and five
can look like so I kind of know where
I'm going I don't know all the pieces
I'm gonna focus on the most important
actions I need to take today but this is
a big deal
nail down a profitable business model
with proven revenue streams if I have
not made any offers in the last month if
I don't have an offer if I don't have
something to sell and if I don't know
what my business model is that just
reveals to me I've got some work to do
all right money mindset number nine
specialization the riches are in the
niches so Zig Ziglar put it this way
don't become a wandering generality be a
meaningful specific specialization this
is huge see the temptation is to think
man I should just be able to offer
somebody every everything I'm gonna open
up a restaurant what kind of food can
you get there well you could get fast
food you could get french fries you
could get American you could get Mexican
you get Chinese food you could get any
kind of food that you want I mean you
just get it all and if you're kind of a
jack-of-all-trades you're probably a
master of none like I want to go to the
most authentic
come on hipster non-gmo organic Mexican
restaurant that's absolutely amazing
here in Las Vegas now of course there's
fusion restaurants and that even that's
its own niche like we fuse Asian and
Mexican together it's a special cuisine
but that becomes a niche well here's the
point its specialization if you're
trying to reach everybody you end up
reaching nobody and if you want to
succeed these are the foundational money
mindsets that whether I like them or not
whether they made me uncomfortable or
not whether I said but why can't I just
do like what I want to do and just be
wildly successful at it you can do
whatever you want to do I don't know if
you'll be wildly successful but I do
know that these are almost like laws of
business and YouTube that why are you
how are you different right
specialization there's a difference
between generalized knowledge and
specialized knowledge generalized
knowledge is not that powerful
we're learning from the school system
that I sat through a lot of classes and
thank God actually I don't know about
listen I don't know if I'm thankful for
it I spent a lot of years of my life
studying about it just a random
information from books as opposed to
going towards my strengths and learning
practical skills that would serve me in
life you know what I mean like you
probably went through a lot of times in
school and I'm all for education I know
you know that there's something about
specialization something about being
known for one thing being a master of
something and what we've learned online
is that if you want higher income the
riches are in the niches like what is
the neat that what is the niche what is
the niche for that to rhyme the riches
are in the niches right so Zig Ziglar
said don't become a wandering generality
but being meaningful specific why
YouTube channels fail and why businesses
fail is there's no real differentiation
in the market there's no real difference
difference is better than better is this
easy
no is it worth it to figure it out yes
is it powerful absolutely what am I
saying to figure out how you're
different how's your YouTube channel
different and if you I want to remind
you nobody else has your fingerprints
even if you're an identical twin you
have unique fingerprints God gave all of
us a unique fingerprint so we can you
leave our unique mark on the universe
and on other people so the goal and the
goal of this community in this program
at is to mine out your difference and it
is to help you double down and amplify
your strengths and become you times two
because you will be different even if
you're by the way in the same niche like
you I think about like I got a friends
that also teach YouTube and literally
have like 30 friends that also teach
YouTube that do it in different ways
there are different ages different
genders different ethnicities different
backgrounds and they're all making an
amazing impact but we all have different
fingerprints we all do it in a different
way we have a different style your vibe
will attract your tribe but on top of
that you got
how you're different we're not just a
tech channel we have the best tips and
tools for creators we learned about
techno dad he does home theater tech we
don't cover home theater stuff different
yeah we're in tech but what's the niche
within the niche double niching what's
what's how are you unique in the
marketplace
sometimes your niche is the actual topic
itself like the tips and tools for
creators sometimes your niche is the
audience what does that mean you you
start a think media style channel but
you're only helping millennial moms
learn YouTube and cameras it's an
entirely different niche cuz you're
really focused on a certain demo I just
learned that especially in in India many
viewers and many people watching one of
the greatest growing languages is Hindi
so you have a your YouTube channel
sharing a lot of the same information or
entertainment even that others are but
in a native language that's a niche
because the differentiation is the
market you're bringing it to like
everybody needs to drink coffee but if
you throw a coffee written in English
somewhere when nobody would understand
what that is then they wouldn't know to
buy it so you check you've actually
taken the same product but you've
packaged it for a different market well
that's differentiation as well right so
this is why YouTube channels fail and so
the mindset is specialization listen
Ralph Waldo Emerson said it like this
the shoemaker makes a good shoe because
he makes nothing else Plato said it like
this each man is capable of doing one
thing well if he attempts several he
will fail to achieve distinction in any
way Wow
do one thing well become the best in
your niche on YouTube become unique on
your niche in YouTube in fact don't even
try to be better necessarily on YouTube
be different and guess what that makes
you the best because you become a
category of one your unique spin on
things you're the only channel that's
maybe in a similar in each but the only
fitness channel for people that work out
in the snow with no heaters you know I
joke but but you you find your unique
corner of the market each of us is
capable of doing one thing well now I
get it you got to learn other thing you
got to learn skills but this is where
you have impact in the market you know
what I mean you want to be the best at
making running shoes you know
Asics debatable if you're a runner this
could start a little fight but III wear
a six shoes I've given a six so many
money I have the Nimbus 17s 18s 1920s
and 21s I just keep giving them money
for running shoes I don't buy dress
shoes from them I don't buy street wear
from them I don't buy suits from them I
don't buy coffee from Asics I don't you
know I'm saying like they the shoe like
they have their specific thing how does
that apply to you on YouTube how what is
your specialization what's your greatest
strength the riches are in the niches
Charles Augustin st. beYOU said if you
want to succeed limit yourself so this
is also a good one because if you want
to succeed you need to do the right
things in the right order phase by phase
now I have a warning for you because
this is a foundational mindset and a
foundational principle but the warning
is this don't over optimize at the start
premature specialization can be harmful
okay so what I mean is you might feel
man the pressure so high though like I
know I want a niche down but I feel like
I'm just trying to experiment still
trying to find my voice I don't even
really know what content I should create
yet start creating content let's go back
to the basics get these money mindsets
listed up get your VRA work book filled
out be thinking about it but at the same
time be creating content and if you're
kind of unsure feel free to experiment
try different styles of videos remember
at the early sessions we did in this
module of video ranking Academy we were
talking about how early and Sean thinks
I was doing
you know a cooking video and I was doing
a vlog video I've logged for 50 days I
realized I don't want to vlog it was
like it for me it's I discovered and I
also looked at the results it wasn't
just because of whatever I've thought
okay I was thinking through the whole
thing I played the whole scenario out
and I was like where's this all going
what's the sustainability of this what
is it I want for my family and my time
and my freedom I want to be able to
batch videos it's harder to batch vlogs
although I know people who do it
sometimes they'll cut one day into like
three days so that they get time off
whatever key is I just want to encourage
you to not feel like you have to over
optimize at the start so what am I
saying I'm saying that these are
critical big vision big term mindsets
but I don't want you to feel limited and
get into analysis paralysis
in the moment I still need you taking
massive action punching fear in the face
punching pressing record premature
specialization also can hurt because
it's nice to try a couple different
things I've got three YouTube channels
that failed that helped me to the two
that succeeded and they weren't failures
because sometimes you win and sometimes
you learn they were the education of
learning myself learning my voice
learning a video learning how to edit
learning learning sometimes you win
sometimes you learn I didn't feel the
reason I'm successful is because of the
failures that I've gone through because
those failures were education so
experimentation is great but where you
really break through on YouTube and
here's what this looks like
I've been noticed for 10 years my friend
and we just started a second channel
called think marketing to get more
specialized to think marketing podcast
subscribe if you haven't subscribed
Google iTunes Spotify the think
marketing podcast and kind of shifted
away from think media so why so we could
get more specialized but hear me that
was 10 years later so I'm still saying
how do we specialize how do we niche
down how do we not be known as wandering
generalities in the market but
meaningful specifics don't over optimize
at the start but but take massive action
at the start I did on thick media I was
I was like what's my voice what are my
videos here's the thing I was making
videos you need to make a video and then
money mindset number ten when I grow my
income grows my when I grow my income
gross listen these were some laws that I
learned why YouTube channels fail and
why businesses fail and one of the
reasons businesses fail and honestly why
YouTube channels fail is that leadership
breakdown at the top
also known as founder dysfunction okay
so now we got to get real I know that I
know you're in this program for the
tactics and the tips and you're like
Sean why you all up in my business and
you can always skip to the next session
but we're talking about mindset we're
talking about the psychology that's
foundational to our success and there's
something about realizing that the
success of our youtube channel it's not
gonna fall on your partner it's not
gonna fall on somebody else it's not
your brothers responsibility such a
parent's responsibility that no one else
is gonna show up but you to get this
thing done and that success rises and
falls on you and it falls on your
shoulders and it falls on your
responsibilities and not only did I have
to own that when I was starting my
youtube channel but I have a unique
perspective now because now I lead a
team and years ago I realized I didn't
even know how to lead a team I don't
know how to hire people I didn't know
how to lead people I didn't know I I was
missing a massive amount of skills so
what I what I learned is I had to learn
new things I had to change I had to grow
I had to deal with my BS my belief
system I don't know what you thought I
meant my beliefs I didn't deal with my
BS I had to deal with my other BS I had
to deal with my issues and I know this
can get heavy but like at the end of the
day the reason YouTube channels fail and
listen it they might even succeed and
then crash and burn because the founder
dysfunction you grow to a certain level
of success but then something breaks
down because of the pressure just
because of discipline or because of
consistency or because of character and
I'm not trying to get all up in your
business on all of those areas but I'm
trying to shine a light to say listen
when I grow my income gross
okay and when we think about founder
dysfunction like we've all seen like an
athlete a movie star social-media
influencer self-sabotage haven't we
or we've seen people that eventually
there's anger issues or discipline
issues or motivation issues or money
management issues so you've got to know
that your net worth will always be in
direct proportion to your personal
growth and development and so this law
is when I grow my income grows so what
do I do
I just simply make a commitment to
growth that's why we say get one percent
better with every upload that's why we
say continue to just get one percent
better but don't just work that's what
this program is all about right it's
about working on your videos but it's
also about working on your communication
it's about working on your confidence
and your camera confidence it's just
about growing and you remember my first
video man was ridiculous my mic attached
I be energetic and entertaining you
remember early on we saw Heather's first
video that did amazing but her voice was
all high pitched and the lighting was
terrible but all we're trying to do is
grow and get 1% better with every upload
you're gonna have to learn new skills I
remember I don't have a website I don't
have my buttons and so instead of saying
well I just wish things were different I
said no I gotta change and grow
I'm gonna have to learn something new
I'm gonna have to learn new skills I'm
gonna have to deal with my BS I'm gonna
have to keep working at this and there's
something about doubling down and
working on your strengths but psychology
and experts have revealed that you do
also have to work on your weaknesses you
can't make an excuse of just wow it's
not what I'm good at I don't know how to
build a website figure it out everything
is figure out a bull I don't know really
how to like tell a story well figure it
out I don't really know how to edit
video figure it out
I'm not really sure how to design stuff
yet figure it out and I want to
encourage you you're capable you're able
everything is figure out about you have
to go as fast as everybody else
but you got to commit to just say look
if I can get better and YouTube is the
greatest personal growth system I've
ever been a part of you got to be
everything man I've had to learn how to
like be the director the producer the
editor the talent the optimizer the
marketer the
search engine optimization specialist
you gotta be a tall so I've just had to
grow in new skills but I've realized
that when I committed to skill
development your net worth will always
be in direct proportion to your personal
growth and development and there's
something about acknowledging the fact
that it's never external environments
and circumstances that cause you to
succeed or fail fail it's always about
your internal environment what do I mean
of course and I'm deeply empathetic we
went through a pandemic and out of their
control restaurants were caused a
shutdown and because of not having
enough money saved up or even the
ability with only opening at 50%
capacity the margin on restaurants only
like 10 to 20 percent so they're like
crippled by being told they can't open
so of course like in some circumstances
external things happen that actually can
truncate a business's success but that
doesn't have to make that individual a
failure for a life because failure is
only temporary they could pivot to
something else we did another coaching
call recently with a woman who is moving
online and moving into Live Streaming
because she has a travel business in
Mexico and her restaurants closed her
travel excursions are closed the whole
thing was closed down but she goes I've
been through this stuff before I'm
pivoting into something else well you
know that shows me is it shows me that
she is not becoming in a victim of her
external environment in circumstances
she's realizing that her internal
environment her psychology her own self
belief her own confidence her own
ability to figure things out
has her pivoting for success it's a bad
economy right now and I'm deeply
empathetic to people that are struggling
and facing that but listen people have
always made money in bad economies there
is always someone succeeding even in a
bad economy and a lot of that has to do
with your community and your psychology
because we can either get bitter
or we can get better and so how does
that happen
I got aggro I got to learn something new
well might when I grow my my income
gross I got to grow my confidence I got
to acknowledge my weaknesses I got to
deal with my BS my belief system I got
to learn new skills I'm going to learn
new look knowledge I got to get new
perspectives I got to develop sharper
instincts that's why we created our
camera confidence course is to help with
mindset and confidence and listen it's
about becoming more valuable because if
early your money mindset if your income
is directly correlated to the amount of
value you add to the marketplace well
then what happens when you get more
valuable well simple math you get more
income so when I grow my income grows
you may have heard before
the more you learn the more you earn
because when I grow my income grows and
entrepreneurs who succeed spend time
with personal development when I was
stunned II studying founder dysfunction
entrepreneurs that had wild success in
Silicon Valley in startups but then came
but then under the pressure of that
success people started realizing they
were like horrible leaders they treated
people bad or like just different things
that happened to him they imploded their
own success so this principle of dealing
with founder dysfunction and dealing and
growing as a leader I know this might
feel overwhelming it might feel heavy
but I'm here to tell you the truth I'm
here to help you get results I'm here to
help us all face together as a community
that when we get better right when we
learn when we grow when we become more
valuable that our income will grow as
well so tell me below which of these
money mindsets do you need to adopt all
of them is there one specific one which
one troubled you the most which one
inspired you to say yeah that's real and
I'm not gonna necessarily go work on
that immediately right remember it's all
about getting focused right now and
saying this whole thing was to get clear
and to develop a business model and a
business plan guess what I'm actually
not a big business plan
and guy in terms of like google how to
write a business plan write a 40-page
business plan you do you that's awesome
but there's something about a napkin
plan like what's what's my plan look
what's the business I'm in and I like it
to be able to fit on a napkin because
simplicity is power complexity is the
enemy of execution but what business
model are gonna be in what are you gonna
sell
what's your niche who's your target
audience of course all of that sand your
clarity worksheet your your workbook and
these money mindsets are the
infrastructure of I really believe
sustained success on YouTube and I want
to encourage you these are a couple
sessions to take with you remember
download the kajabi app so you can be
logged into the course take this on your
own time and listen to these two
sessions over and over because
repetition is the father of learning and
the mother of mastery when you listen to
these sessions over and over you're
going to be able to have them trigger
new things and new seasons of your life
I've learned that sometimes I've had to
just listen to the same thing over and
over and I listened to it six months
later I'm like shoot am I even doing
that yet great I'm glad I'm listening to
it again because I'm reminded again all
this is do it two and a half years later
I'm kind of doing it and I'm like oh wow
I just heard a new dimension of that a
new perspective perspective on that and
it's helped me go further because
probably one of the biggest commitments
if I just sum it all up that has changed
my life in business is a commitment to
growth a belief that when I grow my
income will grow when I grow my team
will grow I don't mean it's even size I
mean that when I get better and become a
better leader that will trickle down
then when I become a better husband my
marriage will grow that when I get new
skills and new capabilities and that
goes down to the foundational mindset
that I can figure this out
that everything is figure out able and
that I don't care how fast I go I'm only
trying to get 1% better so that's that's
doable you can get 1% better in every
area you could be 1% funnier in the next
week if you really worked on it right
you could be 1% richer you're like Shawn
I got like a hundred bucks this is you
only need another dollar that'd be one
more percent like you could you could go
from a hundred thousand to a hundred
one pretty fast it's 1% brick-by-brick
step-by-step repetition is the father of
learning and the mother of mastery and
so summing up this entire section of
revenue the revenue conversation the
best ways to start making money on
YouTube remember influence comes first
income comes second I want you to
reverse engineer the best revenue
sources for your channel like we went
through a lot and it's not about getting
like shiny object syndrome or looking at
too many things it's saying okay what's
the what's the nest next best step for
me and then it's also saying maybe
that's like phase 3 because right now I
just need to focus on posting my next
video I need to keep working the VR a
system and I need to get 1% better with
every upload and I know where this is
going and remember plans change on the
journey but if you fail to plan you plan
to fail so you got to just kind of have
a plan then take massive messy action
and continue to grow in the process get
1% better with every upload because when
I grow my income grows and a couple
resources make sure you get your tickets
to growth video live of course your
tuition waivers or we'll have
information in the members area below
here so you can follow up on whatever
access you have to the conference or if
you've already claimed those and you
want to go to the event you can always
get all the information at growth video
live.com and then check out additional
resources in your workbook and in the
notes below every video like throughout
the entire course there's always
additional resources or notes or just
important information below the video so
if you ever have a question or something
look there first and then also you know
when we talked a lot about the business
model side of all of this stuff that's
not the main point of video ranking
Academy right video ranking Academy is
about mastering YouTube and we're
obviously delivering all kinds of
opportunities whether that's ecommerce
you know sell something online courses
that's not that is not what we
ultimately teach in video ranking
Academy that's what we cover in our
inner circle program which is all about
membership sites and landing pages and
Facebook marketing and Facebook ads and
how do you build a website and how did
he get by buttons and I want us to stay
focused though but if that is something
you haven't heard about yet or you just
want to learn more about that's always
at think inner circle dot-com but
remember your one ranked video away and
when that ranked video is set up right
connected to smart revenue streams then
the game can really change remember we
looked at Omar he put out one Lightroom
tutorial and connected it to him selling
his Lutz and photography's made
thousands of dollars one video he works
mainly putting out two videos a week on
thick media so he rarely uploads to his
YouTube channel yet he has passive
income coming in like crazy from one
ranked video will be every rank of it
won't be every video you post know but
when you keep posting one video a week
you're upping your chances of hitting
that one ranked video following the
process connecting it to smart revenue
streams and don't forget great things
take time and patience but one breakout
video can change everything so keep
posting and don't forget that commitment
is the foundation of all great
accomplishments we dealt with a lot of
stuff in this we dealt with a lot of
heavy stuff you know a mindsets thinking
but we got to stay committed keep things
simple post your next video get one
percent better with every upload and
stay committed to this program stay
committed to your channel stay committed
to yourself stay committed to your dream
stay committed to your family stay
committed to the Y and the reason that
you're doing all of this so that was the
second five money mindsets you need to
succeed and make money on YouTube and
this is part two so I want to encourage
you if you haven't listened to part one
catch the first five in part one but I
want to pass the question off to you
which of these mindsets you need to work
on or what was an aha moment during this
training you might have noticed that
there are some very practical things in
this training as well like your income
is directly correlated to the amount of
buy buttons you have on your website or
your income is directly correlated to
the amount of offers you make to the
marketplace and you say well I make no
offers and I have no buy buttons and
then I go well that's maybe why you have
no income so there's some very
practical things in here and so I want
to know from you though what was an aha
moment for you if you're watching the
video podcast drop it in the YouTube
comments if you are listening to the
audio put it in your journal put it in
your phone you know write it down
somewhere or tweet me or send it to me
on social media because I would love to
hear what an unlock was for you I'm at
Sean Connell rhymes with YouTube channel
on all the platforms that is s EAN
lastname Cannell CA and an e ll and I
would love to connect with you this
episode of course was brought to you by
video ranking Academy and that was just
one of the sessions that is in the
Academy if you're just hearing about
that program and you'd say you know what
I get it
I really want to crush it with YouTube
like I want a master youtube and I want
to be a part of a powerful community of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs that are
crushing it on YouTube then go to start
VR a calm for the details of how you can
join our online course and coaching
program there's a couple really cool
things that are happening right now
right now when you enroll in the program
you get two tickets to our event called
growth video live that's happening
September 2020 online so you can watch
from anywhere in the world and we're
gonna have some highly interactive
sessions so it's not just like a one-way
livestream it's gonna be a very powerful
online experience and so you get two
tickets to that there's some other
bonuses there's a private Facebook group
and then right now you can get 80% off
of the total stack like all the
different bonuses and private monthly
group coaching calls and some other
things really cool stuff all the details
are at start VR a calm you know our
value here at the think media company is
to help you with the strategy psychology
and community and you know at the as
we're talking about money mindsets most
of the RAS about strategy it's about 20%
of success though I agree with Tony
Robbins on that one that like you got a
no it got out of the right strategy the
right tips and steps and mechanics but
he's absolutely right that I actually
think the other 40% of success is
psychology in the other 40% is community
and the psychology is getting your
emotions right overcoming fear
overcoming the imposter syndrome
overcoming the fear of other people's
opinions punching fear in the face and
taking action working on your inner game
working on your mindset your emotions
and your belief system and we cover a
lot of that just like in the session you
just heard and if you want more of that
you can check it out it you know start
VR a calm and then of course community
though show me your friends and I'll
show you your future you're an average
of the five people you spend the most
time with you're an average of the five
of the books you read of the podcasts
you listen to of the videos you watch of
the content you consume listen you are
what you eat
it shouldn't surprise us right
you know if yeah what I've learned this
especially I'm 36 years old my
metabolism is not the same as it was
when I was 21 years old and I learned
that man I can go on vacation for a week
and it's pretty easy to pick up five or
ten fifteen pounds you know just to eat
a few things and that all of a sudden
turns into Who I am it's also true about
what we listen to what we read what we
hear who we are surrounded by so that's
not a call to separate from your family
because you're like my family man
they're pretty they're a little crazy no
no I mean yeah of course you got your
friends your family in your community
but what it is a question of is are you
connecting with other ambitious Purpose
Driven visionary creative people who
overcome excuses people who don't allow
you to stay in your excuses people who
challenge you people who cut you man I
love the proverb that says better the
wounds of a friend then the flattery of
an enemy you know true true love speaks
the truth true love doesn't tell you
what you want to hear true love tells
you what you need to hear and true love
is gonna call you on your BS and say hey
you need to change you need to stop that
toxic behavior you need to punch fear in
the face and change your future and
actually post the video you need to
stick with this you need to shake off
that discouragement jump up and take
some action
because you got greatness in you but
it's on the other side of taking some
massive action it's about community and
so that is what you get in the video
ranking academy you get all the strategy
through the courses and and coursework
and the workbook and all the worksheets
you get the mindset training and then
you also get connected to a powerful
community in the private Facebook group
once a month myself or somebody from the
media team does a private group coaching
call that's forever you get lifetime
access to the program right now that
won't exist forever it's gonna
eventually be like Netflix either
annually or monthly because we just
can't sustain but if you get in right
now its lifetime access and and then
you've got the VRA show monthly every
month we bring on somebody from the
community and we've had so many students
get silver play buttons people that
started by the way they didn't like
start it like 999 thousand subscribers
and then like got their next one once
they joined people that started at zero
zero join the Academy silver play button
a lot of people who've bolted on streams
of revenue to their business have
learned how to leverage YouTube to grow
their existing business for people that
wanted to follow a path similar to mine
and really kind of be a business-minded
contact trader and learned how to really
not use make a living from YouTube but
use YouTube to make your living right
like YouTube's a marketing channel
YouTube is a distribution platform it's
not about YouTube
it's about connecting with the person on
the other side of the camera or the
earphones or the iPhone speakers it's
about connecting with people all around
the world with over 2 billion monthly
active users on YouTube and of course
all the different other platforms where
there's online video and power to reach
people right now and even podcasting
like this and by the way video
podcasting in fact there's all training
in there on video podcasting and what
we're doing with the think marketing
podcast it's a video podcast so there's
a lot of powerful things happening on
the think marketing YouTube channel
along with the video version of this
podcast and it gives us the opportunity
to also then distribute on Apple
on Spotify on Google on the various
platforms but all that is I want to
encourage you check out start VR a calm
of course you can go to the show notes
link in the description below and see
all the details about our current offer
that's over 80% off with all of the
training and the tickets to grow a video
live and the bonuses and the Facebook
group and everything else so check that
out start VR a.com that brings us to the
Apple podcast review of the day today's
review comes from dr. DB Gilbert and he
says solid insights to use in all areas
Sean Connell and Heather Taurus and the
rest of the team are not only insightful
and experts in this area but they really
care for the listener and want to help
us be successful everyone will gain
value from this podcast dr. Daniel B
Gilbert dr. Daniel appreciates you so
much thanks so much for being a part of
our community and for rating and
reviewing the podcast if you've been
getting value out of this podcast
whether you loved this episode or you've
loved one of the past episodes it would
mean to the world to me - Heather - the
think media team if you took some time
to head over to Apple podcasts and just
rated and reviewed the podcast if you go
to the search on Apple podcast on your
iPhone or whatever player you download
on Android to get to podcasts and you
simply go to search type and think
marketing I mean where you may be
listening to this now but maybe you're
on YouTube and you're watching this head
over look up the think marketing podcast
you'll see me in a blue checkered shirt
on the video I'm wearing the exact shirt
I've got a little think cup in my hand a
little orange background and click on
the podcasts and just rate it and review
on Apple iTunes and that would mean the
world to myself and the team and help us
reach more people because look we are on
a mission you may have heard that but we
want to help 10,000 people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with online video why well i my life has
been changed by online
I'm a college dropout small-town kid and
my wife almost died in 2009 and I found
myself in a hospital room with a wake-up
call for six days by my wife's side
trying to say man what am I gonna do how
am I gonna provide and I'd been through
a lot of different things already in my
life working on building my video
production business called clear vision
media waiting tables at Red Robin at
that time we were going through the
housing crisis the the big short
happened we had a rental property
the tenants lost their job they weren't
paying for that it was an 80/20 arm loan
that was a nightmare and so that was
defaulting and everything was happening
there the house we were living in we
were living in with multiple families
because we were trying to invest for the
future during the whole real estate wave
and we were just some young kids we got
married at 21 you know it was just a few
years later than that that we were going
through all of this and and then the
church that I was working at part-time
also started to fall apart because some
of the senior leaders stole some money
and you know some of the stuff that was
happening behind the scenes in their
life and whatnot just wasn't really what
was happening publicly and that's why
we're on a mission to help people not
just achieve success but it's used'
success without losing their soul
holistic success you know come on let's
grow our influence on YouTube let's
let's grow our businesses but let's also
do it without you know betraying our
family let's do it
we're all gonna make mistakes we're
gonna make tons of mistakes we're gonna
let people down let our spouses down or
let our kids down or let our team down
but but there is something about never
letting greed or success itself or
followers or fame be the driving force
those should be I think byproducts like
you might get famous but is that the
goal because that could probably be
pretty fleeting you might get wealthy I
hope you do that's the plan but its
wealth by having first things first just
our priorities in order so that's our
vision here at the think marketing
podcast in our brand
and I want to thank you for being a part
of the mission and the reason we want to
help 10,000 people be successful as I'm
grateful I started to discover the
Internet started to discover YouTube
started to discover affiliate marketing
and I started to go all-in in 2009 and
2010 and I struggled and I wandered
through the desert and I went to
conferences and bought courses and
bought books and found my gosh we're
living in a world where you can build
financial freedom we're living in a
world where you can make money online on
your own terms
and where you can for my driving values
I was saying man how are we gonna pay
our medical bills how can I work from
home how can I provide for my family how
can I have the flexibility in case
whatever comes with my wife Sonia's
health and what's gonna happen after the
hospital and what's gonna happen next
and the reason I wanted to build a life
on my own terms was not so that we could
just go to a beach and sip pina coladas
and make online internet money which by
the way come on let's do that - like
might as well do that as well you know
what I mean that's awesome but but it
was not the motivation it was like man
family our future our faith like legacy
that was a driving force and we've just
been so blessed now over the years and
we've gotten to connect with so many
incredible people on the think media
team who share our same values and share
the value of one an impact people change
lives and believe that we can make a
great living while making a difference
in the world right now living in the era
of the most opportunity that the world's
probably ever seen internet low-cost
tools global connectivity free platforms
like YouTube in these social media
platforms the Gateway to entry is really
your hustle dealing with your belief
system taking action and having the
right strategies and so that's what we
want to do we're on a mission to give
back and and help people and of course
we're running a business I believe our
products and programs are the best in
the industry and that you will always
whatever you invest in any of our
products and programs by the way if you
never do cool awesome
like it's up to you like hope states
connect to the pie
guess like no pressure but we know that
when you invest in any of our products
and programs you're always going to get
at least 10 X the value I believe 100 X
the value and that's what most of the
reports we get back are that wow I
thought like think media and think
marketing Condon was amazing I didn't
realize how incredible these products
and programs were gonna be but hey if
you're like in a tough time right now or
it's not the right time for you or if
you just don't even you know you don't
want to invest in them it's like yo you
can you can come to the mall and just
walk through you could you know eat the
samples at Costco you don't gotta buy
anything you know like whatever like
it's up to you
we're good but I really believe that one
way or another we're here to serve you
we're here to help you and we're so
grateful that we are connected to you
through the think marketing podcast if
you got value like it share it rate it
review it wherever you're listening or
watching please spread the word and you
know what time it is it's time to take
massive action it's time to punch fear
in the face punch perfectionism in the
face press record what do you need to do
next hashtag action takers write it in
your journal write it block it on your
calendar and let's put this information
into action let me know your aha moment
from the day on until next time keep
crushing it keep smashing it and I will
see you or hear yet or your homie hear
me or you're probably here Heather on
the next episode of the think marketing
podcast talk soon
[Music]